over the weekend more than a million and
a half people on Twitch more than a
million people on Twitter and more than
four and a half million people on
YouTube watched a stagnant image of a
black hole on screen although their
favorite game had its server shutdown
what the [ __ ] happened with for nine
last weekend all right let me tell you
this story just like every season and
for tonight history Epic Games playing
this special event to commemorate the
end of season ten now
notably for the purposes of this story
season ten wasn't exactly well loved by
fans of fortnight oh my god this game is
so bad bro I'm not enough I'm not to
just uninstall this past season
introduced mechs may be the most hated
item in the history of the game and
while the game saw a bit of a decline in
viewership on Twitch classic titles like
wow and minecraft actually were
reinvigorated and took over the top spot
for a fan of the game like me it's kind
of felt like four might hasn't had a
high moment since booga won the World
Cup back in July
[Applause]
I think from anyone who's a fan of for
tonight
it's pretty clear that epic needed to do
something big to commemorate the end of
season so where do they do well a few
days before the event was set to start
for night started to tease the end of
fortnight and of course everyone in
gaming was meaning that this game that's
somehow been larger than life for like
two years was somehow gonna just be gone
forever and then in one fell swoop the
entire game was sucked into a [ __ ]
black hole which I mean yeah that's cool
at all another event another sweet
animation in fortnight but it's what
happened next that was really
significant absolutely nothing I'm not a
scientist but I think that is a black
hole and that's it what are we doing the
entire game got sucked up into this hole
and then damage was just still on the
screen and the entire collective
fortnight world found themselves still
staring at that exact image hours later
and it was in that suspense that
everyone was sent into absolute
pandemonium the game servers were down
you literally couldn't play fortnight
all you could do was stare at that
screen everybody wanted to know what was
gonna come next did they kill fortnight
did the Matt blow up I see you watching
my stream yeah you're sick of looking at
the black hole huh you're sick and tired
of looking at the black hole but I
[ __ ] see you and I know you're behind
there I know you know the [ __ ] truth
somehow after literally erasing the game
hours after this happened for that was
given a huge metaphorical shot near it
was like the whole community rallied
around watching this game not happen the
game went from being viewed by fifty to
ninety thousand people as usual to over
a million and a half people in just the
course of a few hours and all that was
on the screen was that stupid black hole
for tonight also went dark across all
social media they changed everything to
that same black image this moment in 49
history triggered the largest virtual
group hang I've ever seen
you just had every major personality and
creator on Twitch looking to kill time
and waiting for the new invent it was
like when you were 14 and the power went
out and you were forced to talk to one
another for example typhoon stream
actually peaked at more than 340
thousand viewers that night watching him
myth cloak and xqc do nothing but kill
time the East Coast you know this [ __ ]
yeah actually isn't it if you're not
[ __ ] 40 you know that [ __ ] and then
in the wee hours of Tuesday morning it
happened
[Music]
[Music]
a brand new [ __ ] map fortnight - as
everyone was joking about this map is a
completely different map Polly different
app does not even anything resembling
the old horn I don't think after almost
two full days off dead servers at 6:35
a.m. Eastern Time a brand new version of
fortnight Island was available to us
this time with countless new points of
interests boats new weapons hundreds of
stylistic upgrades new cosmetics new
heels 20 vaulted items and [ __ ]
fishing rods and once again twitch and
YouTube obviously popped off sitting
back and watching all this I've got a
little bit of a theory of why it
happened like a lot of games I think
epic knew that fortnight needed an
extended downtime the fact is the game
blew up so quickly and epic has been
sort of rushing every month to keep
everything up to date but sometimes for
that little stuff you know the way the
trees look and the grass looks and how
the game feels and sounds you need some
extended time to get that stuff right
and so they staged a way to do that by
blowing up the island and what we got on
the other end was from my perspective a
new and improved fortnight
well hello yeah you knew that I couldn't
sit in this uncomfortable stool and talk
about fortnight without a couple
negatives this new upgrade to for
tonight is a little buggy and there's
some complaints from the community
especially the competitive side that a
lot of the mobility leaving the game has
made it kind of hard to point
there's no mobility though bro it's
crazy you know there's those times where
it's like oh [ __ ] I don't have any mats
I don't have any [ __ ] heals all right
let me drop down a launch pad and W key
this guy oh wait well at least I have
shock waves oh wait you take a bounce
for the guy oh wait oh let me grab the
hoverboard real quick and launching his
[ __ ] head oh wait wait [ __ ] yeah you
anything but other than some slight
tweaks here and there this is actually
the most positive I've ever seen the pro
community react to an update in many
ways this new chapter is actually a
return to form in a lot of ways for
fortnight it strangely reminds me of pub
G Ola they've vaulted many of the
wackier items in the game and there's a
real boots-on-the-ground feel to the
gameplay now no more launch pads no more
stink bombs
no more mechs no more hoverboards and
they've actually nerfed a lot of the
human it's got this sort of me versus
you field where we're shooting and
building against one another and your
kit doesn't matter as much and despite
the fact that it feels impossible to get
across that giant ass map right now it
feels pretty good and I think this
entire saga over the weekend actually
sort of shows to me what's really cool
about fortnight and no I don't mean the
stupid [ __ ] dances my mom hit me up
to ask me what was going on with four
nights we had Lady Gaga tweeting about
the game they have this way of telling
this sort of wordless story where the
game changes every few months and all of
a sudden the world just can't get enough
of it again and even meets someone who
wouldn't be caught dead trying to Craig
90s on a Saturday and fortnight could
not keep my eyes off of that black hole
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub buddy and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]